Service Oriented Architecture is, is often of interest at the enterprise level.
That is, big corporations or organizations who have a suite of
applications that they want to adapt to internet type situations and
rather than rewriting the whole suite from scratch, they want to re-architect it
into a service oriented configuration. This can be tricky, as you might imagine.
Any time you're dealing with large amounts of code and rearchitecting them.
You can run into issues of, of reliability. And there's many a story of
a lot of wasted money leading to systems that don't work as expected. So, in,
in doing such rearchitecting, ultimately you have to take code that maybe was
used to running on a mainframe in which a code was controlling it's own fate.
It was in charge control-wise for calling the various pieces. Have a service
oriented type architecture over the internet, and it's intended to be providing
user functions, then it may have to be switched in to a reactive type system.
That is, responding to the user interactions. This is a major change to
any system to do this. The point I'm making here is that there's a cost in
doing this and there's a high degree of risk because of that cost.